there was a moment early on in the
George Floyd trial where the entire
thing should have been over the judge
should have dismissed the case with
prejudice admonished the prosecutors and
apologized profusely to Derek Chauvin on
behalf of the state of Minnesota for
this coordinated effort to destroy his
life and I'm talking about testimony
from the chief medical examiner in
Minneapolis a man named Andrew Baker a
little over a week into the trial he was
called by the state to make the claim
that Derrick schin had committed a
homicide by placing his knee on Floyd's
neck for several minutes and
that's exactly what Andrew Baker did on
direct examination then when Dereck
chauvin's defense lawyer cross-examined
Andrew Baker it all fell apart over the
course of more than an hour Chin's
lawyer got Baker to admit a series of
facts that taken together undermine the
prosecution's entire theory of the case
for one thing Baker admitted that just
days after Floyd's death he told
prosecutors that Floyd had a lethal
level of fentanyl in his system under
Norm normal circumstances Baker also
acknowledged that Floyd had a severe ly
enlarged heart that the autopsy showed
no physical signs of neck injury or
strangulation the medical examiner went
on to admit that if Floyd had been found
alone in an apartment building his death
would be certified as an overdose
without a second thought then chauvin's
lawyer delivered what should have been
the kill shot he asked Andrew Baker
whether Derek chauvin's knee had ever
obstructed Floyd's Airway and here was
the medical examiner's response to that
question watch in terms of the placement
of Mr chauvin's kneee
um would that
explain
anatomically why Mr Floyd would that
anatomically cut off Mr Floyd's Airway
in my opinion it would
not well that seems relevant I mean in
fact it seems like the whole thing it's
the whole case the entire narrative
surrounding the death of George Floyd up
to this point was that chauvin's knee
blocked Floyd's
Airway that was supposedly why he ran
out of oxygen and stopped breathing now
an expert witness a prosecution witness
for that matter was admitting under oath
that Chin's knee was not affecting
Floyd's Airway at all this
cross-examination received basically
zero media attention at the time no one
seemed to notice it but more than two
years later Andrew Baker is finally
getting some scrutiny now because of a
lawsuit filed by a former Minneapolis
prosecutor named Amy Sweezy as reported
by Alpha news late last week and
discussed on Friday by Tucker Carlson
Sweezy just claimed in a deposition that
Baker privately privately acknowledged
that there were no quote medical
indications of asfixia or strangulation
in Floyd's death quoting from her
deposition she says quote he called me
later in the day on that Tuesday and he
told me that there were no medical
findings that showed any injury to the
vital structures of Mr Floyd's neck
there were no medical indications of his
IA or
strangulation according to Sweezy quote
Dr Baker said that if Mr Floyd had been
found dead in his home or anywhere else
and there were no other contributing
factors he would conclude that it was an
overdose death for that reason Sweezy
said in her new deposition that Baker
seemingly suggested to his colleagues
that they needed to lie about Floyd's
death due to public pressure quoting
again from the deposition quote he said
to me Amy what happens when the actual
evidence doesn't match up with the
public narrative that everyone's already
decided on and then he said this is the
kind of case that ends
careers now at the time of Derrik Chin's
trial we didn't know all of these
details all these conversations that
were happening behind the scenes but but
honestly we didn't need them we didn't
need to know that because they're just
confir confirmation of what any
reasonable person should have figured
out which is that all of these experts
were lying about George Floyd there was
the body camera footage of George Floyd
saying I can't breathe several times
before he was ever put on the ground
you know he's fighting with the officers
in the back of the squad car then then
he begs them to put him on the ground he
asks them to put him on the ground
because he doesn't want to be in the car
the jury saw all of this there was also
the testimony from the Doctor Who
treated Floyd in the emergency room who
admitted undercross examination that
Floyd's symptoms specifically the lack
of oxygen to his brain were consistent
with a fentanyl
overdose by the end of the proceedings
even the jury that convicted chovin was
obviously aware of what a farce this
whole trial was shortly after they voted
to convict several of the jurors gave an
interview with CNN and let's go back and
listen again to their reasoning listen
we got to the point actually that um we
realized for charge 2 at some point I
think it was jod I'm pretty sure it was
jod said wait a minute does
the
intended Act of harm have to be the
death of George Floyd or can it be him
not providing the life support and it
was like all of a sudden light bulbs
just went on for those people I think
that were undecided or or on the not
guilty side yeah go ahead I want to hear
from from you Jody why is it you you
brought that up what did you I brought
that up because tell me what you brought
up in why I brought up to the fact that
this is not what he did but more or less
what he didn't do he did not provide
life saving measures for George Floyd
when he
knew that the guy was in pain or needed
medical attention even the um
firefighter that was off said check us
Pauls check us pulse well then they
checked his pulse and they said well do
you want to do anything no we're leaving
him here he had ample to roll him over
and start CPR and he didn't he didn't
move one bit and even when the EMS came
up and checked him he never even got up
okay so keep in mind that even now even
today after the trial is over we've
heard from the jury why they convict him
we're still told that uh Derek chovin uh
kneeled on George Floyd's neck and
killed him murdered him and that's why
he's in jail when the jury themselves
they they say that that no in fact it's
just he was having an overdose and Derek
schin didn't assist him didn't give him
medical assistance while he was having
an
overdose which is that's what the jury
says that's what happened in the trial
that's not what the media says the
public that's not what anyone out there
says the jury says it's it's it's it's
not what he did it's what he didn't do
he didn't live up to the police
department's motto of caring he didn't I
don't know start mouth-to-mouth CPR on
George Floyd therefore he's a killer
he's guilty of second deegree murder is
what they're saying now a couple things
about that first of all you can tell
from how they're talking about this and
they they go on to talk about their
light bulb moment that's the phrase they
use that they were trying to find an
excuse to convict derck shovin from the
beginning they knew that chovin didn't
actually kill George Floyd and they CA
that caused maybe some cognitive
dissonance but they also knew that they
had to convict him or the city would
burn down and they'd be
racists that's why they were so relieved
when this woman says well actually it
doesn't matter that chovin didn't kill
Floyd it's h it's you know it's not
about what he did it's what he didn't
do which is totally wrong and
nonsensical but it gave them an
out the jury went into the trial
determined to find chovin guilty the
only thing they needed to figure out was
why they need to figure out why they
would convict him they knew they would
it's just a matter of finding the why
every Halloween you hear about the
dangers in the candy your kids will get
but this year the real tricks are in the
meat aisle good ranchers wants you to
take the trick out of your meat and
they're throwing in a treat for my
listeners for $30 off your order with
promo code Walsh at goodranchers.com lab
lab grown meat is becoming more and more
popular foreign meat can be labeled as a
product of the United States and the
mRNA vaccine development is on the rise
for agriculture what's in your meat is
even more in question than ever before
amidst these haunting truths the real
hero arises good ranchers the number one
place to get America's best pork beef
Chicken and Seafood delivered is with
good ranchers their products are
transparently sourced allamerican and
delicious when you shop at good
ranchers.com you don't have to question
what's in your meat or where your meat
is coming from they even have 100% G
American guarantee and a transparent
vaccination policy take the mystery out
of the meat aisle visit goodranchers.com
use code Walsh to get $30 off with free
express shipping on your box of
America's best meat and seafood today
that's code Walsh for $30 that's code
Walsh for $30 off your box today at
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
you know it's hard to take your family
to the movies these days you never know
what kind of woke nonsense they're going
to spring on you sexual innuendos crude
language the emasculation of men and
let's not forget toxic feminism that's
why we're excited for the award-winning
miracle in East Texas directed by and
starring Kevin Sorbo this film should be
a hilarious and family-friendly comedy
and traditional Hollywood style full of
quirky laughs while telling an evoking
but true story about entrepreneurship
the American dream and the value of
forgiveness Sorbo Studios wants to get
wholesome values back into your theaters
make sure you get your tickets before
they sell out this film has already
received the parents television and
media Council seal of approval miracle
in East Texas opens on October 29th and
30th go to Sorbo studios.com for
ticketing and all other information
that's sorbos studios.com now this is
exactly the opposite of how jury
deliberations are supposed to work what
a jury is supposed to do is look at the
evidence and then see if under the law a
crime has occurred and in this case the
law required the state prove Beyond a
reasonable doubt that Derek Chin's
actions caused George Floyd's death that
should have been the entire focus of the
jury but the jury didn't bother with
that because the state never proved that
anything like that had
occurred there was nothing that proved
Beyond a reasonable doubt that Derrick
chovin killed Floyd or that he could
have saved Floyd for that matter
now to give you an idea of how corrupted
the judicial system is shovin didn't
have any obvious alternative to this
outcome if he had chosen a bench trial
he still would have been convicted
that's because the judge was Peter
Cahill he's handled the cases of every
officer who was involved in detaining
George Floyd and recently he sentenced
one of those officers to towel to five
years in prison we talked about that
case uh several weeks ago well what was
two tows crime he held back the crowd
that was badgering and threatening
officers as Derek schin were strain
George Floyd tuta didn't lay a finger on
George Floyd he wasn't even looking at
the arrest because he was focused on the
crowd that's why he was there his only
crime was being in the general vicinity
while a black man overdosed on poison
that he willfully
consumed that's why he's in jail mainly
because Tao never bent the knee to the
Mob he quoted scripture during his
sentencing hearing and that infuriated
judge Peter Cahill who soia threw to
behind bars for 5 years simp simply for
being there while a black man
overdosed now what could explain this
judge's conduct as you might have
guessed he's a lot like the jurors he
believes that Equity is more important
than the law after the Chauvin case
Peter Cahill gave a lecture to a bunch
of other judges and during his remarks
he told his colleagues to um quote work
for Equity he also told them that every
case every case is about racial Justice
watch and finally I want to talk a
little bit about uh racial Justice well
first of all how many of you work in a
courthouse that has Equal justice under
law somewhere emblazoned on a wall or
over your entrance anything like that on
a
plaque okay it's very common if you see
even you know the US Supreme Court above
the entrance Equal justice under
law I think one of the things we have to
do and this is the probably the more
serious part is of this lecture we have
to acknowledge
that equal justice under law stated on
top of the entrance to the building is
more a goal than it is an
accomplishment I think we're getting
better but we are Far Cry from being
able to say we've done it and rest on
our
morals more often a goal in my mind than
an
accomplishment now he goes on and on
like that uh for a while he says it's
important to work for Equity he
encourages affirmative action hiring he
tells everyone to attend implicit biased
training is exactly what you would
expect and proving again that Derrik
shovin had no chance the the the cards
the deck was stacked against him
completely he had no chance the result
was determined before he stepped foot in
that courtroom which is what makes uh
the Derek chovin verdict one of the
greatest injustices in the history of
the American court
system now a few moments ago I mentioned
revelations in the legal complaint by
former Minneapolis prosecutor Amy Sweezy
there were some other Revelations
related to these lawsuits and one of
them according to Alpha news is that
multiple employees of the henpen county
attorney's office withdrew from the
prosecutions of the other three officers
besides chovin who were on the scene
that day and these prosecutors believed
that charging these other officers
violated their professional and ethical
obligations but this judge Peter Cahill
had no problem sentencing these officers
to lengthy prison sentences Even though
three of the people in the prosecutor's
office didn't want have anything to do
with it it violated their their their
oath of office to be
involved Peter Cahill didn't have any
compunction about it he smirked while he
was handing down their prison sentences
in
fact again if you've been following the
Floyd case for a long time none of these
Revelations are especially surprising to
you it's been obvious from the beginning
that Derek shovin was a sacrificial lamb
being offered up to atone for the
supposed sins of an entire race and now
we have overwhelming evidence of that
and and a lot of people concern
conservatives anyway are coming out and
saying so but speaking of
conservatives one of the things that's
so important about all this new
information is that it underscores the
cowardly and shameful Silence of many
conservatives when this trial was
occurring and before it occurred many
right-wing politicians and activists
didn't really stand up in defense of
Derrick chovin in fact many republican
politicians and Outlets explicitly
accepted the narrative that George Floyd
had been
murdered you know we don't have to go
through all the examp but you can go
back to uh to uh May and June
2020 and you may be surprised by what
some of your favorite uh conservatives
were saying back then about this
case all along was an obvious
scam and the con artists behind it are
are now rubbing it in our faces Patrice
cullers one of the founders of BLM is uh
for example now embarking on a new
career as a nude modern artist she's
transitioned from one absurd form of
performance art to another somehow even
more grotesque form this is the hunter
Biden approach except instead of finger
painting Patrice colors is taking off
all her clothing and making tapestries
with gold and quote vintage mudcloth
from Mali just like Hunter Biden the
point of this new effort is to hide her
own corruption as the independent
reports quote colors is leaning into her
art these days gaining sustenance and
perspective from it she speaks of it as
not just a vocation but a means of
Salvation at one point the impact of
accusations of financial mismanagement
BLM from which she resigned in 2021
wounded her so deeply her mental health
was imperil and she felt her very life
was in danger she says what has
ultimately saved her more than once she
feels is her art now there are pictures
by the way uh of her nude performance
art but I will spare you those um and a
lot of people reacted to this news with
surprise as if it's somehow shocking
that a grifter would find a new grift
but it's the most natural thing in the
world and at this point it takes no
great strength to mock Patrice colors as
a scam artist just like it takes no
courage to admit at this point that
Derek schin did not kill George
Floyd the time to really Point all this
out for conservatives Point all this out
was two or three years ago when it
mattered that was the time to organize
Mass demonstrations in support of the
rule of law to apply maximum political
pressure on the corrupt prosecutors in
Minnesota it was the time for Republican
politicians to speak up forcefully
about this travesty of Justice that's
occurring where they're going to throw
an innocent man in prison because he's
white that's the only reason Dereck
Shin's in jail right now is because he's
a white
guy but none of that happened and now
barring a miraculous Supreme Court
appeal Derrick chovin will spend decades
in prison cities burned innocent people
like David Dorne died for no
reason and Patrice cullors and her ilk
have inspired a generation of race
Hustlers to rise up and sees power in
virtually every major corporation and
University in this
country all this happened because a lot
of people lacked the courage to say what
they knew was right even those
prosecutors in the Minneapolis DA's
office who refused to work on some of
these George Floyd cases because they
saw what a sham it was well they kept
their opinions private at at the time I
mean we're only finding out about it
now the grifters see all this happening
and they're emboldened by it the other
day Ben Crump held an indignant press
conference on behalf of Leonard cure
that's the guy who who tried to strangle
a cop to death got himself shot in the
process according to Ben Crump it's
white supremacy when police officers
shoot people who are trying to kill
them and at some level you almost have
to admire it I mean for all his many
faults Ben Crump like Patrice cullers
understands one thing very well which is
that modern conservatives are the most
passive political actors on the
planet for decades universities have
been slowly transforming into cess pools
of anti-white racism and anti-truth
insanity and many conservatives only
went to war against these universities a
couple of weeks ago after hamas's attack
on Israeli civilians followed by Massive
demonstrations on college campuses on
behalf of the terrorists it was shocking
to Nikki Haley for example and she's now
suggesting that some of these
universities should lose Federal funding
and so are some other candidates you
know she waited for the safest possible
moment to go after the universities and
this is the this is the tried and true
Republican
strategy and yes we should go after them
it'd be a g a good place to start even
if it's an extraordinarily delayed
response but it's not nearly
enough you know it it should be the
default response going forward to to to
any Corporation or school that
discriminates against any religious
belief or nationality or skin
color and if the GOP takes this
seriously you you'll see a lot less open
support for terrorism on college
campuses affirmative action will be
dismantled because there will actually
be some teeth behind that Supreme Court
decision anti-white and anti-asian
racism and emissions and hiring will
stop
overnight that means there'll be a lot
fewer Ben crumps and Patrice colors in
the
world and we'll lose out on you know
tapestries of mud cloth from
Molly but what we'll gain is something
we haven't had in a very long time even
before the rise of BLM we'll have a
conservative movement that actually
conserved
something hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there